this capsule we will see an example of
the execution of alfa pruning algorithm
beta so I hope with this example that
it will become a little clearer
commented what the algorithm runs
and stone eagles this is an example that I
encourage you to see her more than once
if you wish to strengthen a little more
your understanding of the algorithm
so let's suppose we have a game that
the search tree we see here so
we have so much in who are each
take a walk sorry who are each going
do two rounds
after which we will arrive at the end of
the part
what are we gonna do is we go
simulate the execution of the sentry box
pruning alfa beta to identify
what are the paths of the tree that
are the two languages ​​that are going to be
actually cut that will never
explored by the rookie research
thanks to the alfa beta pruning so we
start with initialize note interval
alfa-beta upstream and finishes over the infinite to
the root and so called
recurring yves the mines tour then the
volume access so on until that
we get to a final algorithm to
this moment returns them the value of
utility then visited the final in
returning the utility of 6 the nominee
just above updates its value of
beta so we see that now the
new alfa beta has become less and
finished at 6 and the worship value is
currently considered
flu has formed both at the level of
no one sees here so the value of
the EU currently affected are
to be that's the figure we're going to see the
day next to the triangles camps go
do the simulation to those of that one
look at the other we successor
from our mine it's a final place
again so we see this draw
will return the utility of 11
it does not change the utility value they
have been returned by mine since we are
bigger than six what makes that one
urine that now has to explore everything
it is a successor can return his
utility its min max value to its parent
his parent who is an imac what to him
this moment then did an update of
its interval alfa beta so less
defined becomes 6 since if it's more
great than me the infinite and the nude max
exploit his second success that they
also pass its alpha values
beta which is 6 plus infinity so
after updating his interval he
has passed its alpha and beta value to
his successor to this so our
neck and a mine he also goes
start exploring his successors
so the expert his first one is then to
a final draw that a utility of 4 so to
we will go back to the parents
a utility of 4 the utility that
returned was then compared to the value
of alpha in the interval fabre and a
so the mines to find out if we stop
exploration it makes a comparison
with their alpha values ​​and we stop
exploration if the utility that
returned by a child by one of
successors is smaller or equal to the
value of alpha so that's the insult of
successful little sand cover of alpha that's
the case in this case four future
stations at 6 which means we can
stop exploring other successors
at this draw so we can cut that
participates in graffiti
hasni too we will then go back on
could go back 4 too that'll give
the same thing
so either return the alpha or return
and utility in their codes we've seen
in another capture we return the
utility 4 so the num axis observes a
utility of four wells which maximizes
it does not change its utility value
internal so its minimal value axis that goes
to be returned and so he returns to his
parent mines worth 6 mines sets to
day for comparing shares alfa who
is the one girl less the infinite
so there is nothing smaller or
equal to less finite so up to 6-6 and
papeete at the gala - finish so we continue
exploration and we update the value
of beta so we have not updated
the beta value of the internate the fab
so is the upper bound at 6 on
continue the exploration right on the
second our successors passing
the interval alfa beta who think that
if the interval favetta to the nominees
maybe less finished at 6 so we go
minus the finishes at 6 as an interval
successor then of this one is teen so
an imac what will consider the first
action that brings him to a mini last year
once again these values ​​of alfa
beta we do that until we get
return to 1 in the end this draw to you
return an insult and 14 to his
sponsor his parent to whom a mine mine
because if we wait for a graph a
only action that mines to exist
executed so search in this
part of the graffiti is finished so 14
is going to be shot in imax by a now
a max what it does not hurt is that
it compared with its beta node utility
returned by a successor and in this
this case we have that utility return 14
and greater or equal than the terminal
higher than our interval alfa beta
and that's the condition to stop
the exploration of the clouds is unraveling
successor
a max but also and so we can cut
the research does not explore the others
we success in search is cut off
the max will return its internal utility
which is 14
back on his parent even mine who
minimize by observing 14 it does not change
its internal value of utility which is so
set at 6 is the only mine the supply is going
return a utility of six now
at the root
at the very top first thing that a max
does it is that it compares with its beta
is the utility received from a
successor and greater rigor to his
beta the beta and is becoming one ends up
so if it's not bigger than the most
great treat to + infinity and thereafter
he updates his alfa by taking the
maximum to return utility and the
alpha so in this case also his
sighers that less infinity
so we have a new al fath of a 6
then from its contents the recursive pair
but for the second child from a max to
the root that passed alpha value
and beta so we at alfa 2b todd 6 and over
infinity at its second price our
successors mines who will call him his
first our successors who is one of
maxilly spend his values ​​alfa beta
it's more the infinity we continue like that
until we arrive at an endpoint
the final name that happens to be here
with a utility of 3 so having a
utility of you that will be returned to
parents max the parent max in this case
also to identify who could continue
his research
the first thing he did was that
compare it the utility that had been
returned here that was 3 with his
beta which was more infinity so more
the infinite and not the three most epoch
bigger or equal to plus infinity so
we can continue his parents against
our interior alfa beta and norma same
update its alpha by comparing
with the utility turn three dances
that if the law is already bigger than
three so the lower bound and not
change then rest 6 that's what got us
led to explore the second of the
successor that had a utility of
so that had gone back to the parents
and dance only if we have an update
of alpha since the utility it
returns by the second successor
of a max at this level too and more
large or equal to the previous value of
alpha so the value a mini max honor
to this one is from 7 to 6 who returned
au par amine and in this case our
nomine life what makes it
first he compares the value
of utility that returns and 7 with its
alpha the min for comparison purposes with
the alpha and in this case also we have that
there will return to contradict
with our interior alfa beta 7 is beautiful
and well in the meantime if that anymore the
girls much more serious and she
had the goods much bigger gala 6
and subsequently he updates his beta
which is bigger than the value
of returned utility which is so the
new beta value of gears is on
then continue our draw here
exploits are second of the successor in
passing his values ​​of alfa beta 6 and 7
years 8 of that our max does consider his
first our successors we think it's
alfa beta we continue like this until
reach a final we reach the final
that a utility of nine so it was at
final returns utility of 9 to his parent
mines
we can make a comparison with the
hall once at the level of a
it is useless in fact since
anyway there are no others our
successors so to his parent he's going
still returned his local usefulness
which is 9
we are then at 1 hour max so
if we are at max the nude max makes him
a comparison with his beta in
checking what utility that is
returned to this part if they are also
of the part is what it is in
contradiction with but alpha and beta
specifically with my upper band
for the max so my set
actually I have a part that me
would return a minimum value of nine
which is bigger than I know at
to be the greatest value that I
can reach in all the part to
from the beginning of the game and because of
of that because the value of everything is
returned is larger than the terminal
superior beta for world max i'm going
stop searching and I'm going to cut
donges will not explore the second the
successor of my humax the tilter
local the 2.9 which is just returned
at the top we do not undermine this insult is
returned by the second successor
of a mine which uselessness of nine is in
is smaller than the other utility that
were returned by the first child
the first successor who is to have been
so the utility to this part ci of
graff or the mini max value and this
city ​​that went back to the parents is
returned to parents who give the max on
that the utility of the second child who
is 7 is bigger than 6
which makes the decision that is going to be
taken here is going to be the one to take the
second action and that's going to be associated
in min max value of 7
so as we can see the cave to loud
beta is not always
super intuitive I encourage you so
strongly to revisit this example
more than once to be sure that you
understand the different parts
execution of alfa beta algorithm